il a le pas décidé d'un soldat mais
c'est pour la paix qu'il se battre est
bondé de gens qui s'en allaient à la
manifestation
aurait eu une condamnation Claria vingt
ans Raymond Legault organisé une des
plus grandes manifestations de
l'histoire du Québec
et c'est à cette intersection qu'elle a
commencé en ce moment on est au coin de
René Lévesque et Papineau c'était un des
deux points de départ de la
manifestation du 15 mars en 2003
les gens qui se font des signes de la
paix sur les joues
nous sommes en 2003 les États-Unis
s'apprêtent à envahir l'Irak et demande
l'aide du Canada
partout dans le monde des manifestations
sont organisées pour dénoncer cette
invasion illégale
à Montréal plus de 200 000 personnes
prennent la rue des citoyens de tous les
horizons c'est pas la volonté de du
peuple de l'Occident de faire la guerre
c'est drôle ça quand même
les manifestants obtiennent finalement
gain une cause deux jours après la
grande manifestation de Montréal
jean-chrétiens annonce que le Canada ne
participera pas à l'invasion d'Irak je
pense que ça a été une victoire ça n'a
pas été une victoire totale mais
c'est une des rares guerre auxquelles le
Canada a pas participé d'emblée ça ça
nous donne je dirais un certain
encouragement au fait de poursuivre
différents combats sociaux 20 ans plus
tard Raymond Legault s'implique toujours
auprès du mouvement antiger mais
l'engouement des mobilisations de 2003
semble bien loin en ce moment c'est
clair que sur les enjeux internationaux
c'est pas des grandes mobilisation pour
la période actuelle
pourtant la guerre en Ukraine a permis
de mobiliser à nouveau le mouvement
pacifiste le collectif de Raymond
Legault a d'ailleurs organisé plusieurs
manifestations mais non attiré que
quelques centaines de personnes c'est un
échec de l'humanité à savoir
en finir avec les guerres l'activiste
refuse de s'enlever dans le pessimisme
et trouve du réconfort dans les
souvenirs de 2003 l'Union des artistes
qui était
un des groupements du collectif on voit
les Picard en ce moment d'ailleurs
se souvient aussi de cette grande
manifestation
c'était impressionnant
[Applaudissements]
l'acteur c'était beaucoup engagé auprès
du mouvement anti-guerre il était de
toutes les manifestations habitées par
un sentiment d'urgence
cette journée là il y avait peut-être un
montréaliste sur 10 qui était dans la
rue ça commence à ressembler au peuple
ça c'est ça
[Musique]
une émotion de plus en plus rare qui
appartient presque à une autre époque
croit Luc Picard la force qu'on avait
qui était l'Union on le pue on est
fragmenté mais au-delà de ça peut-être
que en général on parle beaucoup moins
de politique en général on approfondit
pas les dossiers
[Applaudissements]
du 15 mars
citoyen il n'a pas été interviewé j'ai
trouvé ce que je portais mais sa tenue
avait attiré la sympathie des
manifestants autour de lui
né à Bagdad Louis Azaria et sa famille
ont immigré à Montréal en 1949 des
décennies avant l'invasion américaine
était famille musulman l'autre côté une
famille juive des souvenirs d'enfance
qui semble bien loin en 2003 lorsque la
guerre dans son Irak natal est imminente
quand l'invasion est venue c'était
cette catastrophique à 90 ans Louis
azariat veut surtout que la mobilisation
contre la guerre en Irak servent de
leçon pour l'avenir je vis dans l'espoir
que des choses vont changer et que mes
enfants nos petits-enfants
ils vont passer
dans leur vie ils vont être ils vont
vivre dans la paix ou dans un monde il
n'y a pas de guerre c'est pour ces 5
enfants et c'est 10 petits enfants que
Louis de la paix en idéal qu'il juge
atteignable persuadé que l'humanité
finira par se rendre compte de
l'absurdité de la guerre